- I don't think I'm gonna make it.
Like, this is.
("All Funky All Fresh" by
Warner/Chappell Production Music)
I prepped a little bit
up until I started drinking beers,
then I had some fish tacos,
and then I had a lot more beers.
- I've struggled with my weight
since I was in second grade.
I'm now 23.
And since about January, I've
taken a serious investment
into my health and my nutrition.
- Given what I usually
eat, what I've been eating
the last few days has been miraculous.
- My meals tend to
usually be pretty healthy,
but everything in between
is absolutely terrible.
- So this is all I'm gonna eat today.
- They've all got numbers on 'em,
so I'm not gonna screw 'em up.
- Like I like juice a lot, so I think
I'm gonna enjoy drinking them.
- What happens if I just drink all of them
in the next 20 minutes?
- I think it's gonna be
an adventure of sorts.
- All I want is like
to get a sandwich.
Just a sandwich. It's sad
how good that would be.
- I have a serious aversion to cilantro.
It starts to hurt my.
- [Garrett] And that's
what they're eating.
And this is what I have.
- You like that one?
- I haven't tried that one yet.
- You don't like beets though, right?
- No, I think beets taste like dirt.
- [Jordan] I like the first three.
- [Garrett] The best one
by far is number three
which is called liquid gold.
And it is delicious.
- I like the spicy one the best.
That's my jam.
- [Garrett] The last
three juices of the day
had like two pounds of produce in them,
so they're much harder to drink.
- The reason most people
drink like vegetably juices
I think is not for
flavor, but is for the way
that it makes you feel.
- Yesterday, there were
times when I was just like
I could just eat; I could
just go to the McDonald's
across the street and
just be done with this,
but now I've sort of
pushed through the phase
and I'll be like no, I can handle this.
- I'm walking around the
office to get my juice
and we have free lunch today.
There's still all these
sandwiches that look super good,
and I just have to eat stupid juice.
- I've heard that kind of between
your first and second day,
you hit like a fatigue stage
and I think I'm still at that.
- It's a really weird
feeling to not be hungry,
but to want food very badly.
- I didn't realize how
much of my daily happiness
food gave me.
To get me through the juice cleanse,
I wanted to have a physical
representation of my progress.
That's all the food that
I've had the last three days.
- I've just hit like a level of apathy
about the whole thing.
- I'm feeling fine.
Like I feel, I wake up in
the mornings and just like
oh, well I guess I drink juice today.
- I just had a lot of
trouble focusing yesterday.
My brain was pretty foggy
until late in the afternoon.
- It's hard to articulate
the kind of fatigue I feel.
- I'm ready for it to be over,
but I'm not dying to eat either.
- I made it. I survived.
- I'm still just kinda
tired and don't feel
especially healthy or more
in touch with my body,
but it was a good exercise.
- I don't think a three day
long juice cleanse is for me.
I already eat a really
healthy and balanced diet
that includes a lot of vegetables
and already includes juice.
- The past three days
were the right kind of
kick in the ass I needed to
start eating healthy again.
- The one thing I think
it did help me with
was discipline.
You can say no to those snacks.
You can say no to that soda.
- I am drinking juice today.
I do kinda miss it.
- Juice cleanses have
their time and place.
("All Funky All Fresh" by
Warner/Chappell Production Music)